[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 164 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
my name is Marc Randall and this week I
am very excited to be joined by the
wonderful John Faust how you doing John
I'm doing good pleasure to be on podcast
for the first time Oh awesome so glad to
have you here for people who don't know
you do you want to give people a quick
intro into who you are and what you do
at Google sure so my name is John rouse
I am a developer advocate specializing
in cloud gaming I mainly focus on a lot
of the GCP unity integrations and
helping out with the connected games
initiative that Google and unity have
together awesome fantastic
so this week I'm also excited to have
another wonderful person coming to join
us miles Boren's is coming back to talk
to us about nodejs
he last talk to us back in 2017 actually
Wooden had a look so I think there's
probably some new and exciting things
and that and then after that we have our
question the week where I get to ask you
tough questions John about the work
you've been doing connecting Google
Cloud api's and working within unity and
how you do that it'll be fun but why
don't we get stuck into some cool things
of the week where we get sucked into
those other topics
my favorite cool thing of the week this
week is that Google cloud next 19 s
session guide is now available so if
you're familiar with cloud NEX it's that
big flagship conference here in San
Francisco it's big it's bright it's
beautiful and we do a lot of talks about
all the things cloud so if you want to
see what some of the sessions are we
have hundreds and hundreds of sessions
across infrastructure application
development data management and
analytics intelligence productivity and
collaboration oh my god so much stuff
some alpha so if you want to check that
out yeah it's a lot but it's hundreds of
topics so check it out and see what's
going on John what have you got sure so
we're introducing scheduled snapshots
for compute engine persistent disks so
what it means is we have scheduled
automated snapshots on anytime info if
you're liking oh cool so this means that
you can do every six hours or every
Monday and also what you can do is we
have scheduled retention policies as
well so that means you can actually set
it to actually delete those snapshots
every six hours every Monday or every
month oh that's super cool that's really
nice speaking of doing regular things to
compute engines instances there's a new
solution that came out called reliable
task scheduling on compute engine with
cloud scheduler so cloud scheduler is
the thing we brought out
several months ago now for doing
reliable basically Krong scheduling for
items and there's a solution here with
code that talks about how you can use
cloud scheduler sending data to pub/sub
on a regular basis save like on a cron
basically and then reliably parsing that
or doing something or some sort of
operation on GCE
with that and making sure that it works
in a reliable way even if some of your
instances go down or other things like
that so if you're looking to do
something along lists or lines you can
check out that blog post it's got
diagrams and code and all sorts of other
good stuff too another cool thing that
we have going on is one of our teammates
posted a blog posts how to make a
self-destructing VM on Google Cloud oh
cool what that actually does for you is
like suppose that you have a VM that's
been running for a while and you forget
about it and you don't really want to
pay for it you can actually have a
startup script that actually once you've
started your VM automatically starts a
countdown for deletion so you can set it
for two hours a week or so it's pretty
awesome
this message will self-destruct as soon
as you read it or something like that
exactly I have to read in the blog post
I felt like a GCP spy that's fantastic
last but not least we have a new blog
post that's coming out talking about our
a I powered speech giving it more
options lower prices new languages and
voices so if you're looking to do sort
of text-to-speech type operations now we
have support for seven new languages
including Danish Portuguese from
Portugal Russian polish Slovakian
Ukrainian and Norwegian and bokmal I'm
pronouncing that correctly
there's also 31 new voices all sorts of
good stuff so there's now a total of 21
languages and variants 111 total voices
and 57 wavenet voices as well so if
you're looking to create speech from
text you may want to check out some of
those new features that we have
available definitely gonna build some
cool things with that I bet you will
awesome why don't we chat with miles and
go see what's going on in nodejs land as
always I am extremely excited to have
another of my favorite people joining us
on the podcast today Myles Boren's is
coming to talk to us about nodejs Myles
how you doing today I'm doing great
yesterday was my birthday and we had a
lot of fun and I'm in you know
relatively high spirits and feeling
quite positive today it was definitely a
fun time actually got to celebrate with
Myles last night
oh happy birthday miles happy birthday
indeed yeah this is coming on the
podcast your birthday present is that
basically how this works um you know I
didn't want to put too much pressure on
you but it's the highlight of my day
after my birthday
excellent excellent so I know this isn't
your first time on the podcast we did
have you back in 2017 for episode one or
five but if people haven't had the
distinct pleasure of meeting you
you want to tell us about who you are
and what you do at Google I'm a
developer advocate at Google working
specifically on Google cloud platform
and more specifically in our languages
team I actually think we all report up
through the same manager that's fun this
kid this could be like our weekly
stand-up as well within languages I
focus on nodejs
and I do quite a bit of work with our
various runtime teams so that's cloud
functions app engine server lists
containers more recently like in the
last couple weeks I've started digging
into cloud build quite a bit when I'm
not you know working directly at Google
I do a lot of open source work I said on
the technical steering committee of the
nodejs project and I represent the
steering committee on the board of
directors of the foundation house to do
standards work at tc39 and I started to
do some work at w3c and IETF as well so
know what just a couple of things yeah
just a few things yeah you forgot that
you are very engaged in a community
especially meetups that involve food
yeah that's true I do run dim sum Jas I
did not know that was a thing but now I
want to go that I used to run the San
Francisco one excellent awesome so yeah
we did have you back in 2017 talking
about all the node.js things but it's
been a year or so so what's changed I'm
sure there stuff there's a couple
different things one of the things
that's fairly new and I wanted to plug
that I'm excited about is no js' dev so
Google has very recently launched the
dev top-level domain and as part of
launching the domain which has a number
of stages of access so if you really
really cared about getting a domain you
know you could have gotten a couple days
ago for $11,000 I think it's now like
1,100 and by I think it's Monday it gets
down to about 150 bucks so I have a
reminder
set for Monday hopefully I can get a
couple I have on my mind a little
cheaper that it goes all the way down to
$15 will be regular registration but a
number of different partners as well as
individuals who own IP rights got early
access to domains and one of those was
node.js dev the doc dev team reached out
to myself and Franciscan Engelmann who
is another dev rel or who focuses on
nodejs
asking if we'd be interested in using it
for the foundation and in six weeks of a
sprint we put together a static gatsby
website it is based on a whole bunch of
content that the project's been working
on for a while it's a whole new slew of
getting started documentation about hey
how do I get started with node what are
some of the basic concepts how do I even
do a node and so it's a really great
starting place for people who want to
learn about nodejs
it's also an open source project that's
available on github comm slash nodejs
slash nodejs dev so if you're looking
for kind of a low barrier way to get
started and contributing to the node.js
project if you like react if you like
Gatsby if you like playing around with
websites and improving SEO there's lots
of different ways where you can come in
and get involved
nice what can we actually expect to see
on nodejs dev like the lineage so
there's actually a bit of a history to
the content that ended up there which i
think is kind of fun so we have the
current node.js org website and that has
been around for a number of years it's
showing its age a bit and I think around
a year to a year and a half ago working
group spun up around a website redesign
and they've been doing this like super
extensive redesign of the whole site and
as you can imagine when you decide to
just completely replace something
instead of just doing iterative change
it takes a long time to make something
that's feature complete or to build
consensus around the features that
you're going to drop one of the things
that that team worked on was this large
slew of content there was a collaborator
who their name is escaping me right now
but I'll dig it up and hand it over to
both of you so we can include it in the
liner notes awesome but someone wrote
all this amazing content and donated it
to the website redesign group and it was
to live on the slash learn page on that
new site and when we found out that we
were going to get the dev TLD one of the
first things we need to figure out was
okay well what content or we can even
put there and it quickly came up as like
hey actually we have all these
wireframes for the new redesigned
website including this one learn page
and we have seventy to a hundred pages
of documentation why don't we just do
that and so we actually just made what
was originally supposed to be a single
route on the new page into this one kind
of specific landing page and it's
possible that we may just slowly kind of
bootstrap more and more features onto
this page and it could eventually become
the new nodejs landing page altogether
but it may continue to just be its own
separate learning resource page but John
to more explicitly answer your question
all of this is very much up in the air
and it's gonna be very much determined
by who's showing up and who's doing the
work what work actually gets done what
kind of consensus we can build around it
but you know the future is open it can
be whatever the people who are working
on it make it into that's awesome it
looks like all the content is all
available on github so you want to go
and edit it you can you can go play with
it all in there if you want to add or
edit and do stuff to it yeah and we
actually just added today at the bottom
of the page is just an edit on github
button which will drop you right into
the github editor and so it's all just
markdown so if you see a spelling
mistake just scroll down to the bottom
of the page they click that button you
could send us a PR awesome excellent and
I think you were talking earlier and you
said there was some cloud build
integration or something like that you
did some GCP integration there what's
that all about
yeah so for those who don't know cloud
build is a product from GCP I have been
very recently as of like yesterday when
I had an aha moment referring to it as
like server list ops mm-hmm but it's a
really cool product where like with a
yamo file you can describe hey like
here's a container and then run this
command with the container and set a
series of steps you can then connect
cloud build to a particular repo and
then you can trigger particular demo
files like describe builds or docker
files on specific actions and those can
either be pushes to specific branches
the creation of tags or on pull requests
and you can create regular expressions
to filter them all as well so you could
be like hey if a branch is pushed that
it matches this so like for example one
of the things that we do is deploy to
firebase hosting on a push to master
so it Otto deploys with continuous
integration and then the other one that
we have is build and push to staging on
a pull request but one of the things
that cloud built has this kind of
interesting is we have it set up so that
it doesn't run automatically when a pull
request is opened a collaborator
actually has to put in a special comment
and that will trigger the build IC and
the reason for that is what gets kind of
neat with this is internally in the IAM
roles inside of Google Cloud you can set
specific iam roles to the build agent
itself so for example I'm using cloud
build to deploy a firebase and all I had
to do was deploy a new image that is
meant to deploy with the firebase API
and then I gave cloud build itself
I am admin privileges over firebase and
now whenever it runs that script all of
the credentials that are necessary are
already in line so I don't need to
inline any credentials and I can
restrict or add more privileges based on
what the need are but this is part of
the reason to have it so that for
running the build you need to have a
comment from a collaborator we went back
and forth on this quite a bit but it
could be like a resource attack if you
just automatically kicked it off and
then someone could just like shimmy on a
Bitcoin miner what she you don't want to
happening we said that's that's really
interesting how have you got the
integration set up between the github
page itself and writing a comment there
and then like firing off a build on
cloud build because they're not like
hooked up that way so this is just built
into cloud build actually so oh yeah
with cloud build there's a new thing
that's rolling up publicly soon where
you essentially click a button to link
the repo it links the pull request and
using github 'z event based API it
actually triggers an event which we
handle internally on every comment so
it's actually just a box you tick when
you're setting out the pull request
trigger that just says do not run this
trigger unless someone explicitly runs
it so we actually kind of have two
different things going on right now we
have like one check suite where Travis
runs and Travis will run the build
Travis will run the test suite and it
will let us know if anything's broken
and then we can trigger this other build
through cloud build and what it will do
is it compiles the site it builds it we
have a single folder
then it uploads that to GCSE using the
sha of the commit as kind of the the
slug for it and then it puts a comment
in that says hey go to this link and
you'll have a staging version of the
site nice this just makes it really easy
for people when they send PRS we can
kick off a build once we reviewed it and
see that there's nothing nefarious going
on and at that point we have a link that
anyone can go to and look at so people
can review it even like on mobile you
never have to really like have an
environment set up to review it it's
awesome that's super nice actually it
sounds like cloud build and github
integration improved since I looked at
it yeah and it's been really fun digging
into this as well because there's all
sorts of unexpected edge cases that I've
been encountering and it's been really
great working with the cloud build team
they've been super responsive and
they're really interested in making a
best-in-class integration here so it's
been really fun awesome I know you do a
lot of stuff as well on the nodejs
foundation side as well there's been
some interesting foundational work that
seems to be going on recently you want
to tell us about what's happening there
like how you called it its foundation so
the nodejs foundation is a nonprofit
it's a 501 C 6 and you know it has kind
of this mission of sponsoring overseeing
the node.js project and the work towards
it there's another foundation in the
ecosystem focused on javascript called
the JSF it's the Jazz foundation and
they are actually both under the Linux
Foundation as kind of like where they
were brought up and for a number of
different reasons including hey there's
two things which one to a support
financially we found that it was in the
best interest of all of the projects to
look into merging the two foundations so
last October we announced at node
interactive that we were had an intent
to merge the node.js foundation and the
JSF into one umbrella organization some
of the biggest differences for the
node.js foundation itself was that there
are more than one projects in it
actually Express in Lybia VR under the
node.js foundation as well it was mostly
built up to support a single project and
the top-level governance of that project
the technical steering committee was
chartered direct from the board to
oversee kind of everything in the
source side of things there's a strong
separation I think we dug into this in
our last podcast but there's a really
strong separation between the technical
governance and kind of community
governance and the financial governance
so the board oversees finances they
oversee certain degrees of marketing but
the board is unable to tell like node
foundation like hey put this person on
your committee or hey than this PR we
have a community governance process
that's set up or openly governed and
that's how things run and so one of the
interesting challenges here is the JSF
has I think like 15 or 20 projects I
should know that number I don't know it
offhand
give or take yeah give or take 10% but
in the merger we now are gonna have a
structure where we need to support many
projects and so since October we have
been holding weekly open public meetings
we've been broadcasting them on YouTube
and they're all saved and there's
meeting notes for all of them that are
on a github repo github calm slash
nodejs slash bootstrap and this
bootstrap committee has been designing
the governance for the new foundation it
started with a couple weeks of actually
designing the governance for the
committee so we could design the
governance for the foundation and once
we reached consensus on a process it
actually in a really amazing way unlock
this thing we had never really
considered before where the foundation
itself we never really had a process for
how collaborators could come up with new
processes or new committees or new
initiatives that they wanted to run
within the foundation so the first thing
we did was actually design this process
it's a proposal process it's based on
how tc39 designs the JavaScript language
but there's three phases technically
four if you consider stage 0 but it's
like hey here's an idea of something we
want to do is stage 0 stage 1 is hey
here's a rough shape of how we want to
do it to get to stage 2 you need to
actually have all the documentation put
together and agreed upon by the
community that hey this is exactly how
we want to run it at stage 2 it goes to
the board or to whatever committee will
oversee it to approve that hey we agree
with this and then it moves to stage 3
which means it's initiated so moving
forward the foundation will actually
have a whole thing in place for people
who want to do new things with it the
foundation is being designed with the
top-level committee known as the cross
project Council they'll be
representative
from various different projects within
the foundation itself on that committee
and that committee will be chartered by
the board to oversee chartering other
projects managing budget Code of Conduct
escalations we're actually looking at
having a foundation wide code of conduct
and it's going to be interesting finding
the balance because in the same way that
we kept a clear separation between the
board and the technical project and the
node foundation we want to still
maintain a pretty clear separation
between the cross project Council and
the technical projects we don't want the
foundation itself dictating to directly
how projects should be run but with that
being said we're pretty opinionated
about what it means to be openly
governed and what makes healthy active
projects so there are things that will
be necessary but we're trying to find
the balance there so like you will have
to have a license it may have to be
within a subset of licenses but we're
not gonna be like you must have the
apache license but it will be like hey
you must have like apache or MIT or a
GPL that doesn't start with the letter A
or like some combination of that we're
also gonna have strict code of conduct
that all of the projects must adopt but
then that introduces interesting
problems like if a project only has 10
or 15 people how do we actually help
them maintain and enforce that code of
conduct if they don't have the resources
to do so so we're looking up spinning up
foundation wide committees to help with
that and there'll be a number of
different places where projects can come
in in different progression so like for
example right now when we were doing the
merger the Libby V project and that's
kind of the underlying abstraction of
system calls that's used in node that
project is healthy and active but don't
have any interest in working with higher
level governance or getting any sort of
marketing support or larger financial
support they just want to like keep the
lights on and have infrastructure
support mm-hmm so we have a way that
they can come into the new foundation
there's no expectation of them having to
grow to do anything more
it's a vendor neutral place for them to
keep their IP it's somewhere for them to
receive the small amount of resources
that they need and to just kind of do
their thing and they'll still be
empowered to come like any member of any
project in the foundation will be able
to attend CPC meetings and be able to
participate in consensus at the CPC but
there will be a smaller subset of voting
members that represent the impact level
projects which is kind of like our top
level I mentioned all these different
things you
to be in the foundation they'll be even
kind of more guidelines for projects
that were considerate impact level that
will have more support and from the
foundation itself I think I spiraled out
there there's lots of stuff so I guess
like in short you know check out that
bootstrap repo all of the governance has
been designed using that proposal
process that I was talking about all the
proposals are documented in there and
you can read them you can see the
history of how we got where we are and
if you're a member of any of the
projects that are involved in the
foundation you are encouraged to open a
PR and start engaging and changing it
show up to any of the meetings and
participate we're trying to minimize the
amount of hierarchy but create enough
structure doing power people to you know
enact the change they want to see we've
actually shared a cab ride and I
remember you giving me the less
long-winded version of this and I can
tell you you're pretty excited about it
and this is this version still pretty
abridged too we could probably do like a
two-hour podcast to me talking just
about this oh my god definitely but
miles I'm curious what does this
actually mean for developers foundations
can often be like a release team it's
like one of those things that you don't
notice until you need it
and generally when it's in a place that
really is like oh my god I'm so glad I
have this in place it's usually too late
like if you didn't have it a good thing
for developers would be like any of the
projects that are inside of this
foundation they should know that
resources oversight and initiatives are
in place to help support that project
and make sure that that project is
healthy arguably if any of the projects
within the foundation are not doing well
that reflects poorly on the foundation
and the cross project Council itself so
I think that there is a certain amount
of comfort that people could have in
knowing that the projects are going to
be maintained the other side too is if
you're a developer working for a company
and that company maybe has stringent
open-source policies or alternatively if
you want to be collaborating on
something in general having the IP of an
open-source project in a neutral body
that's a non-profit significantly helps
organizations collaborate together on
these things so like nodejs being inside
of a this nonprofit in this gender
neutral place to store everything
that'll
companies like Google and Microsoft and
IBM and Intel all to come together and
collaborate and I know at least you know
from personal experience that some of
the organizations that I mentioned would
not like put an entire head count or
multiple head count onto a project if it
was owned by a competitor this just not
smart business so I think also as a
developer
it helps view to maybe contribute back
depending on the company that you work
for in their policies I saw some nice
nice nice
what news we got about nodejs on Google
cloud platform if we had any recent
updates or cool things that have come
out that you want to talk about as well
yeah absolutely I mean there's a couple
different places where you can run node
in our cloud yeah maybe give people a
reminder of where you can run node in
our cloud that's really a good a good
starting point one of the the obvious
ones like the you know kind of the
old-school way of running code in Google
Cloud is App Engine and so we've got
both App Engine flex and App Engine
standard support for nodejs
we currently support the nodejs 8
runtime in general availability and then
at 10 runtime is beta but I do believe
that we're going to be moving 10 to
general availability in short order I
don't have an explicit timeline on it
but sooner rather than later might be a
nice way of putting it that way for
cloud functions we support nodejs we
support nodejs in version 6 and 8 both
of those are in general availability and
in a similar short order we're looking
at bringing out the nodejs 10 runtime in
beta on cloud functions we also have
this thing that's being worked on is
kind of secret but not super secret
because I know I can tweet the sign-up
link but we have this thing that we've
been working on called server list
containers and that's totally a place
that you can run node as well
I mean arguably you can run anything
that's in a docker container that
responds to something on port 80
but you know it is a cool place to put
node and like one of the ways I like to
think about it too is like all of these
are kind of abstractions on themselves
and I think something that we're working
towards and trying to get out in the
node 10 runtime for cloud functions is
like this idea that there really isn't
that much different between a container
an app and a function and you know a
function itself is built with containers
and it just has an opinionated way of
running the code it looks a lot like you
expressed but it's a little framework
that's built on top of node to make it
easier to run your code so if you're
writing code inside of a function and
then you kind of hit this boundary of
like hey you know working within this
one function isn't really giving me all
the flexibility and expressiveness that
I need you can easily take that and turn
it into an app and then deploy it to App
Engine and see you know similar billing
or similar functionality also maybe
better cold start times depending on
what you're doing but if you hit the
edge of like hey this is like the edge
of what I can do with App Engine
standard which is going to have faster
deploy times and it's more managed you
can move to flex or to server list
containers and start using a docker
container if maybe there's a native
module that we don't support or there's
something that you need to do like
spinning up a certain binary or anything
fancy that goes beyond what we offer in
our base image one of the things that I
find really empowering and important to
think about is like their containers all
the way down all of these things and so
it's kind of just like how much sugar do
you want in your cereal and how much do
you want things to be on Rails I don't
know I can come up with some more idioms
yes awesome
really at the end of the day I guess
functions also have the advantage of
eventing right now so you can take like
some event and tie it to a function so
it's really easy to like have something
that puts a whole bunch of things in a
task queue that triggers a pub/sub and
then triggers a function in the
background I like using these for things
like emailers or for transcoding or
stuff like that but overall all of these
different things have their uses and we
can kind of grow with you depending on
what you're doing how you're doing it
and what you need to do yeah sure so
miles what are the places can be
actually you know run JavaScript so
there are a handful of other places you
can run javascript in google cloud
that's really fun and maybe
and think about it you could run
JavaScript inside of any G suite
products with app scripts app script is
JavaScript and there's like a new beta
that you can use to try it out with the
new v8 engine so if you've ever written
functions to you know like edit your
spreadsheets I'm actually using it right
now we're managing a guest list for a
large event that we're planning and
there are like some queries that we want
to do that I couldn't figure out how to
do that inside of sheets so I actually
just wrote a little script and it did it
in a really nice way you can also write
user-defined functions inside of
bigquery so you can write JavaScript
inside of bigquery in case you know your
JavaScript skills are a little bit
better than your sequel skills another
one that you can do there that I find
super fun is like if you're doing
anything with parsing JSON it's like way
easier to parse and manipulate JSON
which have a script than it is with
sequel so you can write you know like
little query functions to do that
I don't know node very well and we're
talking about different node versions
like you said Apps Script is moving to
like the v8 runtime and like on on App
Engine it was moving from like 8 to 10
or something like why would I want to
change the different versions of node
that I'd be using like why do I care as
a developer one thing I could advise to
people who are listening if they want to
learn more about this there's a talk
that I gave called the hilarious
misadventures of being a platform
downstream from your language that kind
of digs into this a little bit but the
the shorter version is node kind of
conflates the concept of an api and a
runtime and it embeds something called
v8 so v8 is did you have a script engine
from the Chrome browser it's part of the
chromium project its own open source
project and v8 gets embedded in a whole
bunch of different places so when we're
talking about like Apps Script the new
version is based on v8 when we're
talking about those like user defined
function stuff v8 is what's executing
the JavaScript so v8 is a JavaScript
virtual machine and it gets embedded in
different places chromium being one of
them node being one of them we embed v8
when we execute your JavaScript code
we're handing it off to that VM and it's
executing and doing stuff with it but
with node it executes your code but it's
not just executing arbitrary JavaScript
it's executing it
with very specific semantics like when
you use require for example that is a
node ism that's an API that we created
for module loading and when you use
something like FS that's not like this
standardized API for file system work
that runs everywhere it is a note
specific API so note itself is that
combination of a runtime and an API
surface and when we talk about the
different versions like node 8 versus
node 10 one of the biggest and most
obvious differences is that 10 has a
newer version of v8 in it because it
came out later and us updating v8 is
assembler major change for all sorts of
different reasons I gave another talk
with no jazz versions how do they work
which kind of digs into that but
essentially it's a breaking change for
us to upgrade v8 inside of node so when
you're on an older version of node like
node 8 you're using an older version of
the virtual machine so it may not have
all the same language features I think
like one of the ones that's in 10 that
is in 8 is like a red dot includes maybe
there's a couple of them the JavaScript
language is standardized and there's new
features added on a yearly basis so a
new version and node is likely to have
new features like Note 8 for example
introduced async/await which is a new
way of handling asynchronicity which I
can bubble about for a long time but no
10 for example comes with a whole bunch
of optimizations to async/await
so the same async/await code will run
like 20 percent faster in node 10 than
in node 8 because when it came out and
no date it was still a relatively new
feature that's the different versions of
node but then there's also all those
different versions of the 8 which
introduced the new features and when we
upgrade v8 in node we get those new
features in node which then in turn
requires us to like update some of our
api's to reflect that so we're in the
process for example of introducing a
whole bunch of new promise based api's
because most of our api's are
traditionally callback based and more
specifically node callback based which
is a very specific way of writing
callback code but if you want to use
async await you want promises so like
for example in node 8 we have this new
API called util dot promise if I so you
could take any API that was written use
a callback based API we turn it into a
promise based API for you but one of the
things that we can do is a run time
because we're directly interfacing with
the eight is we can call like the
underlying mechanisms of creating
promises and v8 itself so we can
actually remove like one promise and a
couple stack frames by doing it this way
so if you use our utility function to
turn your callback api into promise
based api's it will be more efficient
than if you just wrapped it in a
province but people can also just write
promise based api is there's lots of
different ways to do it to your original
question of why that matters really it
comes down to what API surface you want
to do and what language features you
want available and awesome I'm actually
quite interested in cloud functions so
I'm hoping that we can actually sit down
together and hash functions for gaming
yeah absolutely awesome I think I think
for gaming too depending on what you're
doing there's a lot of interesting uses
for cloud functions in general and I
think it'll be cool to get down and kind
of like similar to what I was talking
about where there isn't a huge
difference between functions and apps
and containers there are subtle
differences so figuring out those subtle
differences tend to be like how you can
figure out which of those shapes is the
most appropriate for the problem space
you're solving suite before we run away
today is there anything special that you
want to plug are you going anywhere you
announcing anything mmm anything you
haven't covered today that you want to
make sure we mention before we finish up
yeah well I mean the merger we're hoping
to land officially and legally March
11th of the open source leadership
summit fingers crossed I would encourage
people hey you know there's like a whole
bunch of organizations that you can
volunteer for donate to to help people
get into technology who are from
traditionally marginalized or
underrepresented groups so groups like
black girls code or scripted or girls
who code there's a list we should come
up with a bunch and put it at the end of
this podcast see but I for one loves to
spend my time doing lots of different
things it is not that hard to just
squeeze in a little bit of time to
volunteer for these organizations or
squeeze out a little bit of money to
help support them you know the world's
not going to change by themselves so you
know put some time in this is great
because I actually teach to a program
that kind of functions in the same
fashion targeting you know those
marginalized under episode
group so this is definitely awesome
thing here awesome well miles thank you
so much for joining us today and telling
us all about nodejs and all the fun
things thank you for having me this is a
lot of fun hopefully we can do it again
sometime
yeah maybe 2021 else I'll pencil it in
always a pleasure
so thanks of miles for joining us and
hopefully we'll hear from you in the
near future on a many cool things you're
doing yeah always a pleasure to talk to
Myles getting stuck into our question of
the week though I get to ask you tough
questions which is fun too I hear you've
been having lots of fun
connecting Google Cloud api's to work
within the Unity game engine I think
that's not as easy as it sounds how have
you managed to get this to work so
recently I've been using a lot of
pub/sub and translate and in order to
get those API is working what you
actually have to do is if you're using
Visual Studio as your editor for unity
what you do is you download the nougat
package and it'll download a series of
libraries on your computer and you would
actually have to locate those files and
move them over to a plugin folder in
your unity projects root folder once you
do that you have to create this link
that XML file that actually loads all
these references don't start up because
just downloading new key packages won't
really help you because unity looks for
those dependencies and those references
and all those assemblies that you need
to load up every single time that you
start unity and if your project cannot
have a file that points to those then it
won't start up so that's a great option
to help you get started see and that's
the new get packaged for the Google
cloud libraries yes you can use any nuga
package that has a supported c-sharp
client library oh yes very very cool oh
that's great tip before we wrap up today
John where are you going doing anything
fun and exciting in the near future yes
so I'll be at GDC next month I'll be at
cloud next in two months I'll be at ECG
see it'll be really fun and I will also
be at vector 2019 very nice I like
vector it's a shame that I won't be
there this year yeah so I think we're
gonna be at the same places I will also
be at GDC standing on a gun is and doing
all sorts of good stuff to come check
out the Google booth we're part of that
cloud next we'll be there as well just
got 'told of that we will have a space
on the show floor for the podcast so if
you come into club next definitely swing
by and say hello and I'll also be at
East Coast games conference presenting
as well
awesome well John thank you so much for
joining me on the podcast today yeah
it's been a pleasure and I can't wait to
show in many many episodes
in future excellent and thank you all
for listening and we'll see you all next
week
awesome
[Music]